pues hay que tener en cuenta que este
discurso viene en el contexto de
amenazas en contra de el fbi e incluso
mensajes que se conocen en la red social
de donald trump de querer poner bombas
el edificio central acá en washington
desde el fbi y desde muchos mensajes
violentos que pues llevan a incitaciones
violentas por parte de simpatizantes de
donald trump pero precisamente lo que
quiso hacer yo bailé en este discurso
fue ponerle nombre al problema decir que
los republicanos maga que quiere decirme
que américa write alguien los
extremistas maga son el problema de esta
polarización y de este extremismo que en
este momento vive eeuu dice él en su
discurso el presidente yo bailén que la
democracia no está garantizada que no
hay que darlo como un hecho que hay que
trabajar por ella y por eso es
importante que dijo el presidente by the
bottle salgan a votar y es de resaltar
que en los próximos 70
bien en las elecciones al congreso por
eso precisamente pues hizo este énfasis
el presidente yo bailé en el discurso el
discurso estuvo interrumpido por mucho
ruido mucho ruido que venía de la
periferia de la la plaza de la
independencia donde fue este discurso
precisamente por simpatizantes de trump
que hacían ruido y pues obligaron al
presi del presidente vayan a tener que
gritar estos mensajes este mensaje de
cuidado a la democracia analistas dicen
que este mensaje este discurso a pesar
de que no fue televisado a nivel
nacional por algunos canales si ayuda a
los demócratas a mantener el momentum
que vienen reflejando en las encuestas y
es que en las recientes encuestas no
solamente joe biden ha ganado algo de
popularidad sino que precisamente los
demócratas que quieren mantener el poder
en el legislativo pues han punteado en
cámara de representantes por ejemplo los
demócratas están liderando en ciertos
estados que se creía que iban a ganar
los publicanos así que uno de los retos
más grandes a partir de este discurso
para los demócratas es precisamente
mantener ese momento